[Music]
most of you women watching have been on
a blind date you know what it's like
your friends get you all excited about
this mystery guy
they talk him up
tell you he's smart funny handsome and
interesting you have second thoughts but
your buddies insist you're perfect for
each other
and then you show up
and instead of sitting down for dinner
with john stamos you realize you're
eating with michael moore
he's a mess he's rude he lies
and then he tells you he forgot his
wallet
you're mad at your friends for setting
this up and somewhere in between your
salad and your steak you realize you've
made a terrible mistake
now that's essentially what happened to
america with joe biden the media spent
the last few years serving as biden's
hype man
promising us he's a moderate that he's a
great unifier who will bring the country
back together
competent and calm and they insisted we
were the perfect match because joe was
blue collar biden america always loves a
working class hero so the media turned
joe into one and he capitalized on that
biden sold himself to us as a son of
scranton pennsylvania
i'm very proud of being from scranton i
see it from where i grew up in a town
like this from scranton pennsylvania the
fact is the president can only see the
world from park avenue
i see it from scranton scranton
scrambling scranton and scranton
it's true biden was born in scranton
pennsylvania in 1942
but the family didn't stick around the
electric city for too long by the time
joe was 10 the family had bailed on
pennsylvania to go find a better life in
delaware
according to the washington post in the
1950s scranton was at the start of a
long slow decline the coal mines that
had fueled the city's early prosperity
were shutting down textile factories too
were on their way out and thousands of
people picked up and left for better
opportunities elsewhere
thousands of people left like the bidens
they left to find greener pastures and
scranton has been struggling ever since
according to the u.s census 23 percent
of scranton's population lives in
poverty
compared to just 15 percent back in 2000
doesn't look like joe's done a lot to
help his so-called hometown a senator as
vice president or as president
so what do the people of scranton think
of biden
well we sent some producers there to
find out
[Music]
the president joe biden he's from
scranton it's his hometown um
whoa what do you think that the
president has done for scranton
nothing that i know of
not only has he done nothing for
scranton he's done nothing for the rest
of the united states for the town for
the city of scranton he's done a lot you
know what i mean just i can't put it in
the words right now
i've seen that they changed
the highway to his name so i guess
they're making small changes
why would you name a street actor
do you realize what you've done
so when joe biden says you know on the
campaign trail he's going to hold true
to those scranton roots do you think
he's done that no absolutely not joe
biden does not speak for me he's a
typical career politician you're buying
to me is like a puppet i'm not a puppet
i'm real what concerns do you have that
you feel like are not getting addressed
um inflation the supply chain issue um
gas prices are you getting hurt by
inflation a little bit yeah well
everybody is for sure do you think joe
biden is shutting down the virus
how no
no way oh no it's still here if you
could tell joe biden something what
would that something be joe biden stop
handing out checks a year's salary right
here what i call them
fun coupons
retire and get out of office go home
go home what in the hell are you doing
you don't want to know what i want to
say
we didn't find a lot of biden fans but
can you blame them
the man uses the city as a bumper
sticker to get street cred from working
class people but in reality the blue
collar biden was never that blue collar
according to author ben schreckenger's
book the bidens joe's family has quite a
unique financial history it seems
they've spent their whole lives chasing
inside deals many of which were set up
by other family members
biden's father's finances see-sawed back
and forth when joe was younger until he
got rich quick so where'd that money
come from
he reportedly hunted pheasant
drove convertibles and partied on yachts
that doesn't sound very blue-collar to
me but
how did he afford all of this if he was
working class
it was joe's uncle bill sheen who made a
fortune in world war ii
selling armor to the shipping industry
but when the war ended how did biden's
father stay on top
well he didn't
and that's another story for another day
the biden family balance sheet has
always been full of questionable details
but the media doesn't care to look into
it because it destroys their narrative
biden's just a product they sold to beat
trump and now that product joe biden is
defective
and they're starting to pull him from
the shelves
you remember they told us biden was calm
cool and collected and a wise man with a
steady hand
but he's shown us that he's anything but
listen to how he talks about his son
hunter compared to an actual
professional
he is the smartest man i know i mean
afraid of pure intellectual capacity do
you think in places of political
liability ahead of the midterms
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid son of a
calm down joe no need to get angry
hunter's the smartest man you know but
peter ducey's a stupid son of a we
get it
but this is who biden really is
a cornered grump with a suspect resume
maybe dr jill can give us some insight
into why he's so cranky
maybe it's mansion in cinema driving him
nuts or maybe
he just can't handle kamala's constant
drama
we can't either either way
biden is losing his temper far more
often than normal
ask the right question you've got damn
wire man that's not true why the hell
would i take a test
come on man i'm not confident
what are you doing
go back and read what i said
that is an interesting reading of
english as the media bends over
backwards trying to cover for biden he's
snapping at him
i guess the old saying is true for the
left-wing media sometimes it's the ones
you love
who hurt you the
most but joe is clearly frustrated and
you would be too if you'd lost total
control of your presidency
remember back in march when he said this
about putin
we had a long talk he and i we i know
him relatively well
and the conversation started off i said
i know you and you know me well flash
forward to just last week
i'm not so sure he has uh
is certain what he's going to do my
guess is he will move in
he has to do something
biden doesn't understand putin he has no
idea what's going on
so this is a lesson
whatever the corporate media tells you
it's probably just a sales pitch for a
product they're making money from on the
back end
i think you know exactly what i'm
talking about don't you china pfizer
facebook ukraine open borders
you follow the money and work back from
there
we're putting it together
turns out we're smarter than they think
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else